[Music]
it's a miracle of the kids alive they
may experience mood swings agitation
confusion can you smoke in here i'm
afraid you can't name's floyd dr i told
me that you were a writer would you
consider writing my biography biography
what i'm proposing is that you come and
stay with me and my family until you get
yourself back on your feet aloha jackie
jacqueline floyd's second wife she was a
successful attorney lily lily was
floyd's daughter from his first marriage
is my boy eddie edward he reminded me of
myself hey is that a dead rabbit yeah
pretty much
very good welcome to the family
floyd tells me that the two of you are
working on a book a secret is it
i've done many great things with my life
and everybody's gonna read about it when
the time is right military government
etc what made you join the military well
we'll get to that i'm sorry stuck in my
wits about me it's okay you're doing
great
hey
are you all right is that you of course
who do you think it was
[Music]
i've been looking for you oh thank you
[Music]
i'm intrigued oh there's a lot more
where that came from
you